My functional doctor reviewed my Dutch test results, he ordered her test for me.
You both noted my low levels of bad estrogen.
Okay, he noted my poor results on methylation.
He wanted me to supplement to help with that, but I know you say no to methylated things.
What do you suggest to support methylation pathways with poor results on the Dutch test?
So just because you have poor methylated estrogens does not mean that you actually have a methylation problem.
Just because they're low, methylated estrogens.
So that's not that's that's not really indicative of methylation problem where I would say your key thing with a methylated problem as far as any tested objective tested is.
Is your, if you do a complete blood count in a comprehensive metabolic panel, would be homocysteed.
Homocysteed is your made thing that you look at for having a methylated methylation.
So homocysteed is, if that's elevated, then we do, and your cancer is relatively under control, then we talk about adding methylated nutrition.
Because if your homocysteed is within normal range, and you have cancer, even if you don't have cancer.
Let's pretend you don't have cancer, your homocysteed is within normal range, and you went and did a genetic test and you have an MTHFR gene defect.
So MTHFR is methyl tetrahydrofolate, reductase gene, that's the gene defect that most functional doctors will go, oh my gosh, we need to get you a methyl tetrahydrofolate.
Right away, we're going to put you on MTHFR, four of a folate, we're going to get you a methyl B12, so methyl comolamine, because you have an MTHFR gene defect.
First of all, just because you have a gene defect, doesn't mean that that gene is not working, and how can you tell if that gene is not working, but you look at other lab work, you might look at, in this case, with an MTHFR gene defect, you want to look at homocysteed.
If your homocysteed is elevated, then you do need methyl groups, you do need some B vitamins, and you need some methylation.
If you take methyl groups, and you don't have cancer at all, and you take excess methyl groups, and you have too many methyl groups, it pushes another pathway called your biopterum pathway, which is the pathway better than a pathway where you make all your neural transmitters, and you will make excess amounts of serotonin and dopamine.
And dopamine issues, you can become very addicted to dopamine, and serotonin issues in excess can make you literally kind of go crazy, so you could have these spurts of serotonin, you think serotonin is the happy neurotransmitter, only when it's a balanced excess serotonin can cause rage issues, especially if you have any defects on that pathway.
So, I'm not in favor, I'm looking at one test and diagnosing that. Certainly, I'm looking at methylated estrogens, it does not mean if you have low amounts as I need methyl groups.
Secondly, this is my opinion, if it's rolling out if you want, but secondly, excess methyl groups, what methyl groups do, they silence genes, and they can turn off other genes and you can end up with other issues.
You certainly do not want to be turned it off to suppressor genes, you need to be activating those as much as possible, if you have a cancer diagnosis really, but if you don't have cancer diagnosis.
Most of our cancer patients are eating better, they're eating greens, they're eating, you know, you know, salads, they're eating better nutrition, they're getting plenty of naturally occurring methyl groups, so I wouldn't worry about that.
The only time that I trump, not a cancer patient, not doing taking methyl groups is if they have elevated homocysteine.
So, if you have elevated homocysteine, then we need to add some more methyl groups to your diet to lower those homocysteine methods.